hello I'm Elliot's truck I'm 14 I'm
taking physics petite CSE I'd like to
ask you who is your physics inspiration
and who inspired you to take physics on
well it I think I got my inspiration to
go into science from from Charles Darwin
and Galileo Galilei they were working on
very hard problems they made tremendous
accomplishments and they made science
look really exciting and very important
they're so important that people didn't
like what they found out so I think that
they were my first inspiration when I
was quite young after that there were
many individual people my parents
certainly helped out with my scientific
education by giving me opportunities but
especially I would say when I got to
graduate school and I met my thesis
advisor who showed me really how to do
physics as a research program that was
the main thing that made it possible for
me to do what I'm doing today I credit
many people thank you